[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
29 juin inclus d'eau géants jusqu'au
dimanche 1er juillet dans toute la ville
de plaisir le théâtre espace coluche le
château et le centre hospitalier
accueilleront les enquêteurs en herbe
pour résoudre un meurtre trois murder
party orchestrée par les élèves du
conservatoire de la ville
olivier besson le metteur en scène sera
notre invité ces deux peintres
desjardins et fontaine du château de
versailles une exposition est consacrée
à jean cotten jusqu'au 16 septembre une
vingtaine de tableaux de l'artiste ont
été restaurés ils sont 1 re découvrir
une après midi poétique et bucolique à
la maison triolet aragon ce dimanche 1er
juillet c'est la cinquième édition de
jardins en fête
théâtre musique activités manuelles
mélanie pocket nous donnera le programme
la run and bike est de retour à maurepas
cette troisième édition part du stade du
bois rendez vous samedi 30 juin dès 17
heures pour une course en duo les
participants alterneront entre course à
pied et vélo sur un parcours de 16 km
l'épreuve est ouverte à partir de 16 ans
avec ou sans licence elle semble attirer
de plus en plus de participants selon
l'adjoint au maire en charge des sports
au micro mais annie poker
c'est la troisième année que nous
mettons en place cette course l'année
dernière malgré un temps assez
calamiteux on a eu 1 a rencontré un beau
succès avec près d'une cinquantaine
d'équipages qui ont participé à leurs
neuf matches donc on espère qu
effectivement maurepas va représenter un
rendez vous incontournable de ce type
d'activités sportives pour la région
alors actuellement on a plus de 20 entre
20 et 25 équipages d'inscrits sachant
que cette année la nouveauté c'est que
nous permettons aux équipages de
s'inscrire au dernier moment chose qui
n'était pas faisable auparavant et à
villepreux une course colorée cette fois
l'occasion de la fête de l'été la ville
ganis une vie pro color ce samedi 30
juin à 14 heures un parcours de 3 km
avec des obstacles
accessible dès 6 ans seule obligation
être habillés en blanc sur le circuit
sont implantées des zones de couleurs
pour devenir un véritable arc-en-ciel
une exposition où se mêlent poésie et
photographie l'artiste vincent chauvet
présente une partie de son travail
trente ans de clichés à versailles des
années à explorer les jardins du château
en quête de la saison et de la lumière
parfaite une cinquantaine d'oeuvres sont
à découvrir à la galerie modern art
jusqu'au 8 juillet l'idée surtout en
termes de photographie c'est de
m'intéresser au symbolique qui sont
présentes dans le château de versailles
et non pas pour servir l'ambition d'une
époque et du et d'une personnalité
quitter mu 14 mai pour célébrer plutôt
une alchimie des arts avec le nôtre avec
re amour avec lully avec les fables de
la fontaine sur voie qu est-ce qu à
l'intérieur et qui rend compte d'une
humanité d'une beauté d'une bonté et
d'une forme de poésie aussi donc ton à
mon avis le monde a besoin
[Musique]
un meurtre a été commis à plaisir et le
conservatoire de la ville compte sur vos
talents d'enquêteur pour le résoudre
dès ce vendredi 29 juin et jusqu'à
dimanche 3 murder party sont organisées
dans la ville olivier besson metteur en
scène et professeur de théâtre au
conservatoire est avec nous bonjour
bonjour alors avant de rentrer un peu
plus dans les détails
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas encore
le principe rapidement qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une order partie bien vous avez
presque tout dit c'est à dire que c'est
une sorte de cluedo géant à meurtre a
été commis
des indices sont cachés dans tout
l'espace de jeu il va falloir les
découvrir les décrypter et puis surtout
sont présents tous les suspects de du
meurtre et on veut le public va enquêter
auprès de chacun des suspects pour
essayer de démêler cette sombre affaire
est donc là c'est vous qui avez créé
cette murder party en vous inspirant un
roman d'agatha christie
alors pas du tout je travaille avec une
compagnie qui est la compagnie tisseur
de songes et j'ai découvert les que les
moeurs de partie avec kenan de la salle
debeyre
à peu près deux ans maintenant qui
organise ce type de projet et je
souhaitais qu'ils viennent au
conservatoire pour travailler avec nos
élèves sur ce projet là donc moi je vais
proposer le thème c'est à dire partir de
ce roman d'agatha christie qui s'appelle
un cadavre dans la bibliothèque
on parle du pitch du du roman et ensuite
évidemment on s'en éloigne pour
construire une histoire et c'est cannes
qui a construit qui a vraiment construit
le scénario avec les élèves
alors justement vous parlez de la
compagnie soeur de son jeu voit un
exemple en de murder party qui a été
organisé par la compagnie c'était au
vélodrome en 2016 est donc là il s'agit
de reuze de résoudre un crime dans trois
lieux différents de la ville
voilà un crime dans trois lieux
différents et ont réalisé trois crimes
différent puisque chaque soir le
meurtrier serait différent sinon c'est
pas c'est moins amusant alors on va pas
dévoiler toute l'intrigué exemple un
petit peu d'énigmes dans 10 à trouver
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un meurtre a été
commis dans la bibliothèque au petit
matin monsieur et madame batteries sont
réveillés par leur bonne mairie qui
essaie de les réveiller pour leur
annoncer la sinistre nouvelle ils vont
pas le prendre tous les deux de la même
manière monsieur ban tri essaie de se
recoucher et veut pas se réveiller et
madame 10 et agatha christie lui fait
dire quand même quand on a un assassiné
dans sa maison autant en profiter non et
donc voilà donc à partir de ce moment là
le le le l'ambiance est donnée c'est à
dire que on est à la fois comme celle
d'agatha
dans quelque chose d'absolument mortels
évidemment et en même temps
l'ironie le sourire et toujours aidé et
toujours très proches sur pointes
d'humour absolument donc très british
les trois les trois lieux c'est le texte
le théâtre espace coluche le château et
le centre hospitalier de plaisir donc il
ya des lieux qui sont habituellement
ouverts au public alors le centre
hospitalier ça revient comme une
dimension petit peu particulière de
faire ça là dedans alors l'intérêt que
c'était le souhait c'était déjà d'être 3
d'être dans trois endroits aussi pour
investir la ville pour que se passe des
choses à des endroits où d'habitude ya
pas forcément du spectacle et notamment
la centre hospitalier a souhaité et
souhaite régulièrement ouvrir ses portes
parce que c'est quasiment à à plaisir un
lieu presque patrimoniale et donc il
souhaitait faire en sorte que quelque
chose se passe à cet endroit là j'ai
visité les lieux et puis tout d'un coup
on a trouvé cette ce bâtiment de
centrales qu'il va
le plus ancien de la de l'hôpital et qui
raconte quelque chose qui est
possiblement avec un petit peu
d'imagination certes mais qui est
possiblement un manoir anglais quelque
part du côté dans la grande banlieue de
londres le manoir de garsington on va
parler un petit peu des personnages
parce que vous avez du coup mis en place
dans cette animation avec la compagnie
tisseur de son jeu sur les ailes avant
du conservatoire qui jouent différents
personnages tout à fait alors qu'ils
sont yens olala alors il ya toute une
galerie on a parlé de monsieur madame
bantry évidemment le les propriétaires
de la maison qui manifestement depuis
quelques années sont un peu désargenté
et du coup on fait de leur maison un peu
une maison d'hôtes probablement pour
payer un peu notamment les flics du tout
à ce genre de régression de problèmes au
lait après voilà après on va avoir les
le personnel de maison
et puis comme souvent chez agatha
christie des personnages hauts en
couleur on va avoir un professeur de
tennis
on va avoir une une princesse russe
on va avoir une richissime femme dont on
ne sait pas trop
d'où elle vient mais qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent comme ça des personnages un peu
excentrique qui ne sont pas forcément
tous ce qu'ils ont l'air d'être au
premier abord évidemment qu'il faudra
découvrir tout ça merci beaucoup
olivier besson en a reparlé de ces
murder party donc organisé à plaisir dès
ce vendredi 29 jan à 20h30 alors on peut
s'inscrire auprès du conservatoire même
les plus jeunes peuvent participer c'est
pour tout le monde absolument c'est très
ludique c'est pour tout le monde donc en
famille alors avis aux enquêteurs en
herbe
vous avez jusqu'à ce dimanche 1er
juillet pour y participer merci beaucoup
lire si on part du côté de versailles
pour redécouvrir un peintre un peu
oublié jean cot elle a marqué son art et
son époque le château qui consacre une
exposition au grand prianon plus d'une
vingtaine de ses tableaux sont
rassemblés et l'un d'entre eux est
inspiré les jardiniers du château
un reportage de mélanie poker un bosquet
tout en illusions en son centre jean
cotelle il pas un arbre en plomb irréel
un ensemble le vrai et le faux se
côtoient
ce bosquet du marais aujourd'hui disparu
donc c'est un témoignage très
intéressant de ses bosquets de je dirais
du appartenant au versailles baroque ce
dire le premier versailles celui de
madame de montespan et d'ailleurs il est
dit que ses bosquets à l'origine madame
de montespan l'avait imaginé c'est l'un
des 21 tableaux de jean cot elles
rassemblées par le château de versailles
l'artiste du roi aimé peindre jardin et
mythologie des tableaux restaurés
pendant 5 à 6 ans dont 16 de manière
fondamentale exposé aujourd'hui dans
l'un des lieux les plus prestigieux du
trianon la galerie des côtes elle
c'est un lieu ouvert sur l'extérieur par
des fenêtres du côté des parterres et du
cade côté des jeux du jardin des sources
c'est un lieu où la lumière pénètre est
en quelque sorte les tableaux de
bosquets que vous voyez ici reflète cet
extérieur le roi aimait se promener dans
ses jardins y faire des haltes et de
nouveau à l'intérieur il se repose
devant ses bosquets jean cotten des
jardins et des dieux se vit aussi à
l'extérieur le miniaturiste a inspiré
les jardiniers du château une longue
étude de ce tableau pour recréer la
volonté du peintre plus d'une vingtaine
de variétés de plantes donne vie ce
tableau près d'une trentaine d'oeuvres
font revivre l artiste aux billets comme
une renaissance
[Musique]
c'est l'été le beau temps est enfin
arrivé si vous avez envie de passer vos
week end en extérieur les activités ne
manquent pas celui des juniors de cette
semaine se déroule dans un jardin un
bonjour mélanie longeau camille on va
dans un jardin en fait alors c'est celui
de la maison elsa triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ça se passe
dans un un parc de 5 hectares le rendez
vous est donné le dimanche 1er juillet à
partir de 14 heures c'est la cinquième
édition de jardins en fête une
après-midi politique et bucolique on
écoute un nombre de la maison à triolet
aragon
c'est un moment extrêmement touchant
pour nous ce que vous avez savent
toujours justement à la fin d'une année
scolaire
et c'est un moment où on va vraiment
mélanger les arts et on aura donc des
arts de rue avec un piano manège qui
sera installé mais on aura aussi une
pièce de théâtre sur qui nous sont
ciblerait libre sensibilisera à
l'écologie et les petites mains remonte
aussi à trois mise à contribution
puisque après avoir été spectateurs les
participants seront acteurs alors pas de
panique pour les plus de 6000
ce sont des activités manuelles qui vous
attendent alors avec l'association sol
et vannerie vous pourrez créer des
objets tressés en fibre végétale ou être
des artistes d'un jour en croquant le
paysage avec art passion les jardins en
fête de triel triolet aragon c'est donc
le dimanche 1er juillet dès 14 heures
et puis n'oubliez pas pour vous inscrire
le site internet www.me son tir est
triolet tirait aragon point com qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et puis les vacances approchent à grands
pas les activités sont déjà là
et oui au centre alfred de vigny à
voisins le bretonneux on va faire de
vous des petits magiciens alors j'ai
fait j'arrive à vous apprendre des tours
de close up une spécialité qui consiste
à se produire au plus près de vos
spectateurs
un stage qui vous permettrait d'avoir un
diplôme le stage s'adresse aux
intéressés âgés de 7 à 18 ans merci
mélanie pour ses idées pour les plus
jeunes on passe maintenant à notre
agenda et en parler théâtre
d'improvisation
grande finale de la ligue
d'improvisation des yvelines ce samedi
30 juin les touche-à-tout de chatou
remettent leur titre en jeu de leur
titre de champions du département en jeu
face aux improbables de guyancourt le
public est invité à voter pour désigner
le gagnant alors rendez vous au théâtre
nouvelle france du chéné 7,8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous espérons que vous avez fait
le plein d'idées sorties en famille ou
entre amis on se retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro et d'ici
là je vous souhaite un excellent week
end
m